The two goals of congestion control are
fairness; meaning every send gets their fair share
of the network resources. And efficiency meaning
that the network resources are used well. In
other words we shouldn't have a case
where there are spare capacity or resources in
the network And senders have data to send, but are not able to send it.
So, we'd like the network to be used efficiently, but we'd also like it to be
shared among the senders. We can represent fairness
and efficiency in terms of a phase plot,
where each axis representers a particular user or particular senders.
Allocation. In this case we just have two users, one and two,
and we represent their allocations with x1 and x2. If the
capacity of the network is C, then we can represent the optimal operating line.
As X1 + X2 being some constant, C. Anything to the left of this
diagonal line represents under utilization of the
network, and anything to the right of
the line represents overload. We can also
represent another line, X1 = X2 as some
notion of fair allocation. So the optimal point, is where the network is neither
under or over utilized, and when the allocation is fair. So being on
this diagonal line represents efficiency, and
being on the green diagonal line represents
fairness. We can use the phase plot to understand why senders who use additive
increase, multiplicative decrease, converge to fairness.
The senders also converge, to the efficient
operating point. Let's suppose that we start at the operating point shown in
blue. At this point both senders will additively increase their sending rates.
Additive increase results in moving along a line that is parallel to x1 and x2,
since both senders increase their rate by the same amount. Additive increase
will continue. Until the network becomes
overloaded. At this point the senders will
see a loss and perform multiplicative
decrease. In multiplicative decrease each sender decreases
its rate by some constant factor of its current sending rate. For example,
suppose each one of these senders decreases its
sending rate by half. The resulting operating point,
is shown by this second blue dot. Note
that that new operating point, as a result
of multiplicative decrease, is on a line between
the point on the efficiency line, that the
centers hit, and the origin. At this point
the sender's will again increase their sending rate
along a line that's parallel to X1 equals X2 until they hit over load again.
At which point they will again retreat towards the origin. You can see that
eventually, the senders will reach this optimal
operating point through the path. That's delineated by
the blue line. To think about this a bit more you can see that every
time additive increase is applied, that increases efficiency.
Every time multiplicative decrease is applied that improves
fairness because every time. We apply multiplicative decrease,
we get closer to this x1 equals x2 line.